pull out Falls first patch landed last
week and digital founder you've put it
to the test to see how the update has
impacted technical performance
commenting on the ps4 version digital
boundary said any combat that puts a
strain on ps4s memory bandwidth I have a
usual flurry of affect work now get in
market boost on hatch 1.82 the gains are
remarkable in one early death claw
battle for example going from lengthy
lulz at 25 frames per second and under
when using the minigun or nearby
sandbags to a practically faultless 30
frames per second with the update that
said no performance improvements were
found in some complex locations like a
diamond city but it was concluded that
the update has markedly improved the
frame rate of ps4 comparatively the xbox
one version was found to be largely
unaffected by the patch except for the
core Vega factory which is now
processing at 30 frames per second
digital foundry also found the
stuttering issues in some sections on
Xbox one were not addressed in the patch
and some shadows appear to have been
removed in the cove ager factory
interiors on both consoles let me know
how you're finding fallout 4 after the
new patch and stay tuned to gamespot for
all the latest